ist jesus gar nicht am kreuz gestorben
alles über ostern und zwar
wissenschaftlich betrachtet heute bei
pixum science fiction ostern in der
schnell zusammenfassung karfreitag
stirbt jesus wenn man nach dem
christlichen glauben geht am kreuz und
steht drei tage später von den toten auf
das feiern christen und es haben sich
ein paar riten gebildet ostereier
osterhasen zum beispiel schauen wir doch
mal an wie man ostern wissenschaftlich
betrachten kann beginnen wir mit der
auferstehung und das fest ja gar nicht
da wird es jetzt schon schwierig zwei es
jesus als historische figur bekannt der
jüdische historiker flavius josephus zum
beispiel und der römer tacitus erwähnen
hin
allerdings gibt es für den auferstehungs
mythos eigentlich gar keine beweise die
bibel als quelle stellt bei der
historischen betrachtung ein problem dar
die autoren haben ihre texte über
christus nicht chronologisch
aufgeschrieben wie ein
geschichtsschreiber das tun würde
die geschichten sollen er auf die
zukünftige entwicklung hinweisen alle
autoren der jesus geschichten also die
evangelisten waren außerdem keine
direkten zeugung der kreuzigung und der
auferstehung erst jahre sogar jahrzehnte
später werden die evangelien formuliert
als sie die geschichte schreiben ist der
osterglaube bereits etabliert also
wirklich distanziert haben sie also
nicht geschrieben die texte sind ein
weitergeben des glaubens und keine
wissenschaftliche quelle die
auferstehung selbst wird in der bibel
auch nicht mal beschrieben ist jesus
wirklich am kreuz gestorben auf wurde in
der geschichte vor allem während der
zeit der aufklärung das grab in das er
gelegt wurde und das nach drei tagen
leer war als indiz für eine auferstehung
genommen allerdings wäre auch ein grad
möglich es gibt auch die überlegung ob
josef von arena der jesus auch bestattet
haben soll die nicht einfach in ein
anderes grab verlegt haben könnte es
könnte auch sein dass jesus nur
scheintot war laut des markus
evangeliums war pontius pilatus erstaunt
dass jesus so schnell am kreuz gestorben
war weiter heißt es dass mehrere
personen jesus in der folgezeit gesehen
haben zitat und dass er gesehen worden
ist von käfers danach von den zwölfen
danach ist er gesehen worden von mehr
als 500 brüdern auf einmal von denen die
meisten noch heute leben einige aber
sind
schlafen danach ist er gesehen worden
von jacobus danach von allen apostel
zitat ende
so steht es bei paulus allerdings wird
die erscheinung des vermeintlichen toten
auch so interpretiert dass es sich eher
um eine innere version der anhänger
gehandelt habe und dass das leere grab
als mythos geschaffen wurde um der
vermeintlichen auferstehung eine basis
zu geben
mit historischen und theologischen
betrachtungen des osterfestes setzten
sich die wissenschaftler und theologen
schon lange auseinander
die geschehnisse lassen sich von
mehreren seiten aus betrachten wobei die
historische seite nur sehr schwer zu
beweisen ist wie sieht es mit den
traditionen aus die heute an ostern
praktiziert werden es gibt wohl keine
zeit in der mehr eier gegessen werden es
gilt im christentum ungefähr seit dem
mittelalter als symbol der auferstehung
und tatsächlich gibt es wissenschaftler
die sich mit dem idealen frühstücksei
beschäftigen viele faktoren spielen beim
eier kochen eine rolle zum beispiel der
luftdruck er ist mit entscheidend über
den siedepunkt vom wasser je höher man
sich befindet desto geringer ist der
luftdruck und damit sinkt auch der
siedepunkt also das wasser kocht bei
weniger als 100 grad celsius allerdings
ist eine gewisse temperatur beim eier
kochen nötig damit das eiklar hat wird
da drin ist ovalbumin kurzoper ein
protein das macht 55 bis 65 des eigners
aus um es zum stocken zu bringen braucht
es eine temperatur von mindestens 84 5
grad celsius
das eigelb hingegen braucht nur 65 grad
celsius das besteht übrigens zu 48
prozent aus wasser und zu 33 prozent aus
fett außerdem noch aus eisen kalzium und
phosphor und warum pigs man eigentlich
vor dem kochen an
bisher nahm man an dass durch das loch
luft entweichen könne allerdings dient
das loch er dem spannungsabbau die
schale platz dann durch die beim
erhitzen auftretenden spannungen nicht
mehr
und wie lange sollte man allein kochen
dafür wurde tatsächlich eine formel
entwickelt zunächst braucht das eine
umgebungstemperatur von 20 grad celsius
bei einem mittleren durchmesser von 45
mm benötigt das jetzt exakt 50 8 minuten
um herren weich zu werden also der
eidotter ist dann noch weich ja man kann
aus allem eine wissenschaft machen auch
aus dem kochen eines ice was wäre ostern
ohne den fleiß eines hasen der bringt
dem idealfall kern weichen eier und
versteckt sie beschrieben wurde der
osterhase
erstmals 682 von georg frank von
frankenau danach verbreitet sich die
tradition von deutschland aus über
europa auch in die usa warum ein hase so
ganz geklärt ist das nicht der hase
spielt ja auch im christentum eine rolle
so gibt es bilder von drei hasen so
genannte drei hasen bilder hier teilen
sich drei hasen die ohren wie auf dem
bild erkennen können das ist ein symbol
für die trinität also gott jesus und der
heilige geist eine andere these besagt
dass bei der übersetzung der bibel wo
man aus dem hebräischen wort verfahren
das übersetzt eigentlich klippschliefer
bedeutet mit lepus koloss übersetzt
wurde und das heißt häschen beide tiere
haben ungefähr die gleiche größe soll
ein symbol für menschen sein die schwach
sind um beim christentum schutz suchen
wie feiert ihr ostern wie seht ihr das
mit der auferstehung wird es irgendwann
eine historische klärung der tatsachen
geben diskutiert darüber in den
kommentaren
das gerne einen daumen nach oben da und
vergesse nicht den kanal ist er
kostenlos zu abonnieren
frohe ostern und eine schöne freie zeit
bis zum nächsten mal bis dann bleibt
dran